hey this is presh tall walker
there are seven doors in a line
a mouse starts in the middle at door
four
at doors one and seven are cats
every day the mouse moves one door left
or right randomly
each direction with an equal fifty
percent chance
we can illustrate one path of the mouse
as follows
if the mouse reaches a door with the cat
door 1 or door 7 the game ends as the
cat catches the mouse
in this example the mouse is caught on
day five
the question is
what is the average number of days until
the mouse is caught
i think josh for this problem and i
thank folky for emailing it to me
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video where i
will present two different solutions
[Music]
i'm going to present two solutions to
this problem i'll first go over a
standard textbook method that is quite
complicated but it's useful to learn to
solve other more challenging problems
i'll also present a trick using symmetry
where you can find the answer very
simply
the first method is an example of an
absorbing markov chain
an absorbing state is one that once
reached cannot be left
in this game both doors 1 and 7 are
absorbing states
the other method
is to use symmetry to derive simple
linear equations
and you'll see by contrast how the
second method is much faster than the
first method
but let's get started with the absorbing
markup chain
here are the steps
we'll first create a state diagram that
shows the possible states and transition
probabilities between them
we'll then write the transition matrix
and put it in canonical form
we'll then calculate the mean time to
absorption
i'm going to present a how-to for
solving this problem
and see the video description for a link
to the proof of why this method works
and if none of what i said makes any
sense to you don't worry i'm going to go
over this slowly so you can follow along
and understand this method
so first let's create a state diagram
that shows the possible states and
transition probabilities between them
this game has 7 doors so we'll call
those seven states
now what are the transition
probabilities between the states
well if you're at door one
you will always stay at door one
this is a hundred percent chance that
you're stuck in door one because the
mouse is caught the same thing goes for
door seven
now for any of the interior doors
there's a fifty percent chance of going
left or right so from door two there's a
fifty percent chance the mouse goes left
to door one and a 50 chance the mouse
goes right to door 3.
and this is true for each of the
interior doors so from each of these
doors we have arrows going left and
right with the 50 chance in each
direction we now need to write a
transition matrix corresponding to the
state diagram
as we have seven states we need a seven
by seven matrix where the ij entry is
the probability of going from door i to
door j
so we'll write this in as follows
each row i
will represent the transition
probabilities
for that door
so the first row should correspond to
the transition probabilities for door
one
well where can you go from door one
you can only go to door one
so the first entry
one one needs to be the 100 probability
that it's an absorbing state
you can't go anywhere else so all of the
other columns will be zero
so that's the first row
what about the second row we need to
analyze door two
well from door two there's a fifty
percent chance you can go to door one
so we need the first column to be point
five
there's no chance that you stay at door
2 but there is a 50 chance that you
could go to door 3.
there's no chance you can go to any of
the other doors so the remaining entries
in this row are zero
now the third row will correspond to
door 3.
here there's a 50 chance of going to
door 2
and then there's a 50 chance of going to
door 4 and all of the other entries are
0.
we can use the same method to fill in
the rest of the entries in this matrix
and we get all the way to door 7 where
there's only a 100 chance of staying in
door 7. so the very last entry in row 7
column 7 is 1.
so we now have a transition matrix
but we want to put it in a nicer form in
what's known as a canonical form
to create a matrix p
we do this by rearranging the rows and
or columns
in the following form
so p needs to be a matrix where we have
a upper left block q and upper right
block r
the lower left block needs to be zero
and the lower right block needs to be an
identity matrix
so what does that mean for the matrix
we've created
well essentially we want the identity
matrix to be in the bottom right
so we're going to rearrange the rows and
columns to put this one from the very
first row into the sixth row
so let's rearrange these rows and
columns
so first i'll rearrange this first
column
to put it into the sixth column
next i'm going to put this first row
as the sixth row
so we now have the matrix p in canonical
form
you'll notice we have a matrix of all
zeros in the bottom left we have an
identity matrix in the bottom right
here is our matrix r and here is our
matrix q
now from experience you'll be able to
write p in canonical form immediately
from the state diagram you won't have to
go through the process we did where we
came up with some transition matrix and
then had to rearrange the rows and
column
but i wanted to demonstrate this process
in case you started with the transition
matrix that was not in canonical form
so we can now proceed
as follows q is a five by five matrix
from q we can calculate the fundamental
matrix n
as equal to the inverse
of the identity matrix minus q
in other words
we take the identity matrix with five
rows and five columns and we subtract q
and we end up with the following five by
five matrix
we need to take the inverse of this
matrix
you can use your favorite method to
invert this matrix such as a numerical
solver
when you do that you get the following
result
now the mean time to absorption from
each state
will be found by taking this matrix and
multiplying it by a column vector which
has one in each of the five rows
so we calculate the mean time to
absorption by taking n multiplied by
this column vector of one
and we get
five eight nine eight and five and this
will be the mean time to absorption from
doors two three four five and 6.
so to solve the problem we recall that
the mouse starts in door 4
so reading this column vector
it takes an average of 9 days until the
mouse is caught
so we found the answer and we also
figured out the mean time to absorption
from any of the other doors
but is there a simpler way to solve this
problem
i'll now present a method that uses
symmetry
so we have the same transition state
diagram as before
but look at this diagram and notice the
symmetry from the middle
by symmetry doors 2 and 6 should have
the same expected time to absorption
we'll call this expected time e1
similarly by symmetry doors 3 and 5
should have the same expected time to
absorption we'll call this expected time
e2
finally we'll suppose door 4 has an
expected time to absorption equal to e3
we can interpret e i as the expected
time to absorption where i is equal to
the minimum distance to doors one or
seven
another way of looking at this is let's
re-label our state diagram as follows
we have the two doors where the cats are
as x's these are the states you're
absorbed and then we write one two three
two and one for the interior doors
in this way ei is the expected time to
absorption from the number i in the
abdomen diagram
this model is also an absorbing markup
chain but it involves only four states
instead of seven states
so how will this help us
well let's start if you're at a door
with the label of three
from the label three
after one day the mouse always moves to
a label of two where the expected
waiting time is then e2
so we figured out the expected waiting
time from three
is equal to one which is one day plus
the expected waiting time from two
next if you're at a door with the label
of two
after one day the mouse has a 50 chance
to be at the label three where the
expected waiting time is e3
and a 50 chance to be at a label of one
with an expected waiting time e1
so we can write the following equation
e2 is equal to 1day
plus 0.5 times e3 plus 0.5 times e1
finally if we're at a door with the
label of one
after one day the mouse has a 50 chance
to be caught and a 50 chance to be at a
label of 2 where the expected waiting
time is then
e2
so we can write the equation
e1 is equal to 1 plus 0.5 times e2
so we have three equations in three
variables
and we can solve these equations very
simply
how can we do that
well let's substitute the first equation
into the second equation and let's
substitute the third equation into the
second equation
we now end up with an equation that only
has e2
we can solve that e2 is equal to 8.
we then substitute back into the first
equation to get e3 is equal to 9 and
then we substitute into the third
equation to get e1 is equal to 5.
and we've solved it
the mouse starts in the middle which is
a door with the label 3 so it takes nine
days on average for the mouse to be
caught
we found the answer much quicker than
using the transition matrix method and
we got the exact same result
so this is usually the part of the video
where i ask did you figure it out
now if i don't ask this question
everyone says i wanted you to say did
you figure it out but if i ask it some
people who are watching these videos for
the first time feel it's patronizing as
if i solve these problems and i want to
ask did you figure it out that's not the
case if you watch my videos you'll see
there are many puzzles that i present
that i cannot solve
so i only mean this in jest
and i will not say did you figure it out
if you guys don't want me to
i thank you for watching this video and
i'm going to end on a personal note
since 2014 i've posted one to two math
videos per week that you can watch for
free
with no delays for sick days vacations
or personal life events
so far i've also declined all sponsors
you'll see sponsors on many youtube
channels so far i've declined them for
very important reasons
so how can you help support this channel
and bring amazing math videos to
everyone
here are some of the ways
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos that's one of the best
ways and it's a free way that you can
show support for this channel
i also ask that you watch and share mind
your decision videos it'll help more
people come to this channel
if you have a math topic or puzzle you
can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com i get
contributions from all around the world
you can also read my books there are
links in the video description they're
also great as gifts finally if you so
choose you can support this channel
financially on patreon
and as a small things i'll try and give
you exclusive content like sneak peeks
of future videos and i'll always respond
to you first
thanks for watching and thank you for
your support